[Applause]
for David the streets of Seoul are a
much longed for Safe Haven he's North
Korean one of the very few to have
defected in the last few years
and his journey here was utterly
remarkable
my mother bribed the soldiers beforehand
he tells me as he shows us where he
crossed for the safety of his family we
can't tell you exactly when or exactly
how he left but his stories from inside
are astonishing his father defected
first that ultimately landed his mother
in
prisoners receive around 20 to 30
kernels of corn every meal my mother's
body had shrunk to half her original
size my eyes filled with tears the
moment I saw her she was so disheveled
and gaunts that I didn't recognize her
initially they also beat the women in
prison he was still a child but he was
left to fend for himself and his
siblings they stole food to survive
taking what they could to their mother
my mother said people died every day
from malnutrition she even said that
people would die in the middle of meals
to dispose of the corpses she said they
folded the corpses at the waist and put
them into sacks afterwards the corpses
were buried near the fences of the
prison the stench of the corpses would
come up from the ground in the spring
when it became warmer
David's stories matter because such
recent testimony from the other side of
this tense border is very rare indeed
North Korea was already one of the most
secretive countries in the world views
like this are about as close as most of
us will ever get but the pandemic has
intensified that secrecy those very few
defectors are one of the only windows in
and it seems covert has further
strangled an already dysfunctional
economy David says it's bought fresh
waves of shortage and struggle
all the trade routes were effectively
closed down we depended heavily on
smuggling goods from China in order to
survive I heard from my relative that
more people are starving and prices are
rising they say it's become even more
difficult to live we've been looking at
these Summit pictures and this kind of
coverage it just so much has changed we
are in a totally different era in which
North Korea is really very isolationist
a strictly closed border has made
information harder to come by experts
say it is also it's called widespread
hunger I'd say chronic economic crisis
uh not acute it's just an ongoing
bad situation definitely some people
would would be
in serious health problems due to the
food shortages
symbols of Hope still Line This
contested border although most agree The
increased secrecy will remain life
beyond these barricades is still
shrouded in mystery more now than ever
before Helen Ann Smith Sky News in South
Korea